[Music]
we are here today to commemorate the
75th anniversary of the liberation of
the Auschwitz Birkenau camp and it's the
place and the time which is hard to say
something which will not sound as a
phrase I just will want to share with
you my impression of course I heard all
those horrifying statistical figures 6
million Jews who died 1.5 million Jews
only here on this place I heard many
stories many testimonies of the victims
and of the survivors and what I never
realized before I came to this place how
was it for the mother who had to undress
her child before going to the gas
chamber you only realize you think you
realize how it must have felt on such
place it's very touching it's also very
committing because we all the people who
have some influence in Europe we have to
guarantee that this will not happen
again and we have all the tools in our
hands we have the possibility to connect
the laws enact the laws which will bring
punishment for those who would like to
start the atrocities again we have the
funds to finance education and
enlightenment and remembering of what
happened we I think have political will
and preparedness to address the
challenges of today and to explain to
everybody that we have to join forces
not to let this happen again because
passivity was one of the drivers of what
happened here in Auschwitz Birkenau
so I am here to pay tribute but also to
promise that I will do everything which
is in my power to stop the rise of
anti-semitism and the rise of hatred in
Europe thank you we are here on a soccer
Duty first to honor the million of
children women and men were victims of
the Holocaust to pay our respect to the
survivors but also to send a message
that such despicable acts have no place
in today's Europe I myself I'm from a
town like the Saloniki my home town that
had the sad privilege to send 55,000 of
its people here to die here in Auschwitz
we need not only to be able to remember
but also to speak up and act because
events like the heinous act act in haleh
or in Brussels remind me remind all of
us that we have to continue to be
vigilant Europe and its values is the
better shield we've got to shield
ourselves our societies and our union
from anti-semitism